For Avengers: Infinity War, the Russo brothers
managed to successfully juggle a jam-packed,
star-studded cast of characters without overwhelming
anybody in the process.
That being said, Infinity War did leave a
few characters sidelined.
Some such as Ant-Man and Hawkeye were completely
absent, while others made only relatively
brief appearances.
The Hulk fell into the latter category.
And while the big guy was mostly overshadowed
by his alter ego Bruce Banner after his early
defeat at Thanos’ hands, he surely won’t
be out of action for much longer.
Here’s why.
"And Hulk… smash.”
Inner demons
The Hulk we saw in Infinity War was clearly
struggling with his inner demons not least
the shame of his initial encounter with Thanos.
“Dude, you’re embarrassing me in front
of the wizards.”
As it turns out, however, there’s actually
a lot more going on, too.
As co-director Joe Russo explains on the Infinity
War commentary:
“I think ultimately what it is is that he's
tired of playing hero to Bruce Banner/"
One way or the other, Hulk's unwillingness
to participate in the events of Infinity War
was a crucial part of both his and Banner’s
character arcs.
This has only been a good thing for the Hulk’s
legacy in the wider MCU: as fascinating as
Banner's struggles can be, the onscreen Hulk
has been a little too one-dimensional character
for a little too long.
This twist should bring some new depth to
a character who, for many, is regarded as
little more than a big, green wrecking ball.
And Avengers 4 is as good a chance as any
to solidify Hulk’s legacy as a three-dimensional
character.
Jekyll meets Hyde
In 2018, Mark Ruffalo hinted at a rocky future
for the relationship between Bruce Banner
and the Hulk.
“And the only one banner probably dislikes
more than anything else is Hulk.
And, they're they’re heading for a showdown.”
That showdown he mentions never really occurred
in Infinity War, leaving the door wide open
for these warring personalities to clash in
Avengers 4.
Between Ruffalo's remarks about a Hulk/Banner
showdown and the Russos’ statements about
Hulk getting tired of bailing out Banner,
Avengers 4 could even be the point at which
the MCU gets its first taste of Professor
Hulk a character created in the comics when
Hulk and Banner united into a single personality,
combining the latter’s brains and the former’s
brawn.
Avengers 4 concept art leaked in 2018, depicting
the Hulk in an Avengers team outfit, would
seem to back up this possibility.
Running the gauntlet
Some fans have suggested that, in Avengers
4, Tony Stark will end up going back in time
gathering up past versions of the Infinity
Stones along the way in order to build his
own Infinity Gauntlet.
And if he succeeds, it stands to reason that
somebody with a fair amount of heft is going
to be needed to wield it once it's made.
The idea that this Gauntlet-slinging giant
could be Hulk becomes even more appealing
when you take a Professor Hulk scenario into
consideration.
If the Hulk and Banner do join forces and
don an Infinity Gauntlet, it's hard to imagine
that it wouldn't be a powerful enough combo
to put Thanos out of action once and for all.
A one-sided fight
Another Avengers 4 rumor posits that, at some
point during the movie, the Hulk will end
up losing an arm.
But, let’s be completely honest here — it’s
not like he’d be the first.
“Do I look like Iron Man?
Stark is…"
“I’m sorry - I, oh.
I’m sure that’s going to be okay.”
So what could possibly happen that would lead
to Earth’s greenest hero losing his arm?
Three words: Stark's Infinity Gauntlet.
If the Hulk were to take on Thanos gauntlet
against gauntlet it would stand to reason
that the only way to win would be the removal
of the opponent's gauntlet... by whatever
means necessary.
Take all these pieces and put them together,
and you get a picture of Banner and Hulk uniting
into Professor Hulk, wielding an Infinity
Gauntlet against Thanos and losing an arm
in the process.
Wild conjecture?
You bet but then again, so is basically everything
else surrounding Avengers 4 right now.
The story’s end
We may not know much about what Marvel has
planned for whatever happens after Infinity
War, but we do know that the Hulk's carefully
developed story arc has been one of the most
compelling and crucial elements of the late-stage
MCU.
Mark Ruffalo has made it clear in the past
that we've been watching an entire Hulk story
taking place throughout Thor: Ragnarok, Avengers:
Infinity War, and Avengers 4.
Avengers 4 constitutes the third act in that
arc typically, where the hero faces his fears,
earns redemption and wins a great victory.
This movie won’t just be the conclusion
of the fight against Thanos and the culmination
of the first chapter of the MCU, but also
the climax of the Hulk’s “unofficial”
trilogy, too.